こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです（日本語字幕作成者：今日の一言）
皆さんアニメはお好きですか？アニメ
アニメが大好きです
最近はちょっと見る時間がなくてあんまり見れてないんですけども
皆さん”ラブライブ！”ってご存知でしょうか
ラブライブ！っていうのはね音ノ木坂学院っていう学校に住む
9人の生徒が学校の危機を救うために
そして自らを変えるために
スクールアイドルとなって
こうどんどん成長していくという
アイドルと見せかけての熱血系超心燃える（萌える？）ハートフルアニメでございます
アニメ自体は終わっちゃって
結構日が経ってるんですよ
結構もう終わって”ラブライブ！”熱が結構冷めてるんですけども
なんとつい最近
この”ラブライブ！”の最新作というか
続編みたいな感じで
ラブライブ！サンシャイン！！というものが始まりました
待ってました
もう最後のライブっていうのもあって
それも終わって
もうほんとに悲しかった
悲しかったし正直その
ラブライブ！っていうその流れが一つに終わって
俺は！ちょっとラブライブ熱が冷めてたところがあったんですよ
まあ大好きだけどね
大好きなんですけどラブライブ熱がちょっと冷めてたところがあって
冷めてたところがあったんですけども
今回ラブライブ！サンシャイン！！という新しいアニメがラブライブで始まりました
で、内容はどんなのかと言いますと
この穂乃果ちゃん達
このμ'sの９人
ラブライブで主人公だった９人達のお話がもう終わってて
μ's達９人のお話の後の話でございます
なのでラブライブサンシャインではこの穂乃果ちゃん達とかは出てこなくて
まったく別の主人公
まったく別の新しいキャラクター達でお話が展開されていきます
もうねやっぱ色んな意見があるわけですよ
やっぱラブライブはラブライブで終わってほしかったとか
あんまり語ると怒られそうだな
これくらいにしときましょう
あんまり僕が偉そうに言ってもあれなんですけども
とりあえずラブライブというものがですね
サンシャインという新しい名前を付けてまた帰ってきたというわけで
穂乃果ちゃん！
ここで！俺は！全国の地方の人に言いたい
お前たち俺も同じ気持ちだ
そう
あああああああああああうおおおおおおおおおお
あ、穂乃果ちゃん
アニメがあまりやってないんですよ
東京とかだとアニメはなんでもやってるんですけども
静岡とか富山県とかもっと遠くの地元とかだと田舎の方はね
テレビを見てもやってないアニメが多いんですよ！
わーーーー
いやまじでね
もうねわかるよ
もう皆の気持ちわかる！
静岡にいても富山にいても見れないアニメがとても多いし
時間とかがめちゃくちゃだったりするんで
もうラブライブサンシャインがやってるかどうかも正直わからないんですよ
静岡で
それくらい田舎の人はアニメに対して弱いんですけども
今回なんと
なんと
ラブライブサンシャインがYouTubeで見れてまーす！
ちゃんとした日本語で喋ろう
はいというわけでラブライブサンシャインがなんと
BANDAIさんの公式チャンネルで見ることができます
よっ
もうねホントに良い
ほんとに良い！
興奮...こういう　こういう使い方がYouTube
これぞYouTubeですわまじで
BANDAIさん本当にありがとうございます
ようするにYouTubeで
YouTubeで今なら誰でもラブライブサンシャイン1話2話
まだ2話までしか出てないのかな
まだ2話までしか出てないんですけども
2話が全部24分間全部見れます
で、ラブライブサンシャインはね
実は静岡県がモチーフ...ロケ地になってるんで
ちょっと親近感が　楽しみなんですけども
とりあえずこのYouTubeを見てる皆さん
もういつでもラブライブサンシャイン見れるので
ちょっと...見てね
こうまずラブライブを見てほしい
まあひとまずラブライブサンシャインが見れるということをとりあえず俺はね今回お伝えしたかった
もう・・・お伝えしたかった
このメインチャンネルでもお伝えしたかっ...（カット
はいというわけで
早速ラブライブサンシャイン見ていきましょう
1話と2話が今のところあります
とりあえず俺は今から見ます
その１話見るのでしーーっ
うおおおおおお鳥肌が
立っていなかった　あれ？
＊陽気な音楽＊
ちょっと目に砂が入って泣いてしまいました
いやもうなんかねその
穂乃果ちゃん達μ'sがなんかねやっぱすごかったんだなって思いました
いやほんとにキモイ人って思われちゃう
はいというわけでラブライブサンシャインですね
えーーっとどこで泣いたかと言われるとですね
そのラブライブサンシャインの中で
ラブライブのこのμ's達のメンバーの歌とかが流れると
やっぱこうなんか思い出しちゃいますね色々と
まじで俺ちょっとやばい人と思われちゃいそうだわ
はいというわけでラブライブ好きだった方も
多分皆チェックしてると思うんですけども
是非YouTubeでも見れますので
ラブライブサンシャインチェックしてみてください
え、これ何話まで出るのかなー
ちょっと皆さんにお伝えしたかったなって話でございます
ラブライブサンシャイン是非見てください
ちょっとまたラブライブ熱が熱くなってきました
以上今日のメインチャンネルでした　バイバイ
あ、違った
じゃあな！
～＾ED＾～